Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Consternation 2
If you remember Consternation 1, it was this surreal game that was multiplayer
without letting you know it was multiplayer
It was this non-stop
Terrifying chain of events that passed down from Player to Player in a totally bizarre and surreal and unexpected way
(Was that a JoJo reference?) This is the sequel to that game
I have no idea how this game is gonna play out
But I know that it's probably gonna have a surprise that I'm not prepared for
I don't expect it to play out the same way that it did in the first game
so
w e l l
Okay.
Oh
Cool kid alert
fake!
H A
Yeeaah
What?
I'm sorry?
Is this some SCP crap here? Wait a minute.
Oh
Oh, I really get low.
When Ludacris made that song, Ludacris was clearly talking about me
Um, oh
Press the right mouse button to zoom your flashlight. Zooming your flashlight increases how far you can see?
Oh Wow. Yeah, no joke, okay
Wow sex haha, yeah. Nope. It's here. Whoa. Oh, oh, may I ask what is here?
Because that's important in this discussion.
Can I add some art of my own?
Wow, that's gross
That's very gross
All right,
I hate it when horror games tell me how to sprint.
I don't want to know
I don't want to know how to sprint
I don't want to know that I need to sprint
N   ᵁ   T
Great
why
*pause*
am I here?
Press 'E' to open the map. Oh-
uhhh
Okay, all right, so I'm in the bottom left I think I still don't know what the point of the game is
After turn on night vision uses battery once it's gone, it's gone. I
Don't want to use that then that sounds terrible. Why would I use all that?
Obsidian pixie magic. Okay were those were those written by other players or something?
hee hoo hoo
hehehEHEH
It's very weird. I just don't know what to expect
I never knew much about people until I took one apart.
Ah, that's
scary
the truth happened
Nice
H A W T
What the hell is happening?
This makes no sense
Got em'- Got- what- Got who who'd you got? Alright, um
That's blocked off. I know I
Generally have a feeling of where I am, but I don't know what I'm going for
Or why?
That's the biggest question. I have young wild and free, huh?
That ain't me something about this doesn't make me feel free
*confused* smash tunnel?
Aw, you talking about penis smashing?
hehEHEH >:D
Yeah, I know
Why?
I'm sorry?
You wanna run that by me again?
Actually, you know what? D o n ' t
Don't run that by me again. I don't need anything run by me ever. Okay door. Hey, door. good great. So we're stuck maybe
All right. Good. Great. I get to go back. I'm glad about that. That's a happy thing me. I'm happy about that
That's good. That is very good. That's the goodest thing I've ever heard
Don't do whatever you're about to do. x1
Don't do whatever you're about to do x2
do not do
a n y t h i n g
I swear
*clek*
A A A
WHAT THE
FWACK
*wheeze*
*silence*
*s  i  l  e  n  c  e*
*s   i   l   e   n   c   e*
*s    i    l    e    n    c    e*
O k a y
Two urban explorers were exploring an aban- *begins wheezing*
Just gonna ignore that happened.
*reading*
Oh
No, no, no, no, wait, no, hang on
So that was just the intro, huh?
That was just the intro, H U H ? All right, cool. Good job
Roar, I can do that too, but I just don't feel like it
Cause that'd be weird for me to suddenly just start howling in the middle of the woods alone
Especially after I'm sneaking into a place and I'm sure that all those other urban explorers, you know, they probably brought in digital cameras too
Why didn't we just watch their footage? Huh? Unless they didn't make it out alive, which would be a problem for me
No, but I'll make it this time. I'm gonna survive this is gonna be mine.
I'm gonna make it
All right, can you-
Just cool it? what exactly am I looking for?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah burrf yea burrf. I forgot I could run. I never even tried to run before.
Oooh, Hello! Hi, how are you?
What wow whoa, whoa, what was that
Okay, I'm in I guess
That's a big. Tha's a big honking
That's a big honker. That's a BIG old honker. Um
Soo,
I'm sorry what?
I'm- I apologize- what?
ye wanna run that by me again?
Okay, so I came in someplace with a crawlspace, I mean I either came in from the top left
*Heh* What the fuck was that
don't you screw with me
*hEH*
Okay, I think I must be coming in from the top left that- that's the only thing that makes sense to me right now.
So this just goes back into that hallway
I imagine this is just a way to get out of his path when he comes barreling down at me. I
I don't know if these things are safe, but they feel better than just wandering-
What was that?
Uh pardon- pardon moi??
*GASP*
PPFFACKEE
Hi, okay. Yeah. You are a thing. Okay. You are a thing. Why are you snapping?
I'm just gonna go for it. Just going for it
Just going for it going for it going for it going for it going for it
I need an orange key to open this that's weird and doom like okay. Alright orange key. I need an Orange Julius
So there's some kind of an orange key. I don't know why I
Don't know why I need an orange key, but I do need an orange key apparently
So they're gonna be like an announcement when he comes by or am I just going to be royally boned oh
This is just a running away loop, this is just a runaway loop that's just a loop to run away
I gotta stop using the flashlight in long mode long mode is gonna get me killed because I'm not gonna see him in front of
My face or her
I think I just got to look around
Till I find
Orange
Okay
Okay, I think I made it now okay, I wish I could point it out to you but
I'm like a second group of rooms bought up from the bottom left
In the third room with the yellow dot in the middle of it. Oh, yeah
This is terrifying. I mean this captures the one thing that I love about horror games, which is apprehension
Avert
It's a very important
It's a very important quality about horror games apprehension
The ability for a person did not want to move forward because they don't know what lurks
Around the corner and they don't want to find out that's a
Very important thing in horror games that is missing in a lot of these games. I play these days. It's just that sense of apprehension
It's just so important. Okay, I'm all the way bottom right now. I think I don't know what the orange key
Looks like I'm guessing it's orange. So that's all I have to go on and again, I do not know if these little things are
Safe, but they feel good. They feel real good
Okay, I'm not quite full top right but I'm close to top right I'm just trying to search all the rooms
I don't want it. Why are you you're like a worse version of Baldy you keep slapping
Stop it. I just don't know how am I ever gonna know where he is?
There's like very subtle sound cues besides the snap. There's like some subtle stuff
That like anything like that makes me think that something's about to happen
Okay
I do wanna go I feel safe here. I
Feel small safe. I feel tiny safe
I
Haven't seen anything. I don't know what it's gonna look like when I see it
hopefully I recognize they're not I
See if the thing is like I have no idea how he behaves
All I know is that he killed me instantly last time and I haven't su mning that's gonna happen the second he sees me
It's not as much graffiti oh
Oh, oh oh
Where is it? Where's it? Where's it? Where's oh,
God huh? I'm a baby. I'm a big bitch baby. Okay, there's a the only other place I haven't checked is like the middle
Section. Oh
I hate this I don't like I don't know. I'm gonna actually move over to this one
Cuz I feel like I'll bet better be able to see down the hallway this hallway here specifically Oh
God oh I thought that was a body. Oh god, where am I? Okay, Stan this way. Oh,
Shit oh, okay. Some of these are unmarked little some of these little alcoves are unmarked
I
Don't know. Whoa. What is that? Is that a thing? That might be a thing? Okay. All right. Um, I'm a
Go for it, I guess
Something in this chest the key is in his chest what he's what the kid is his chest whose just
What his chest? Okay
I'm guessing you mean like someone's chest cavity, and I don't know who you're talking about
But I don't want to know who you're talking about. I think I'm in the room
I think I'm in the room second from the top left the square there. I just have no idea where he is
So far so good I just can't get too comfortable is the thing I just can't get too comfortable
Wait, what happened? What the fuck?
What the fuck
What happened?
What?
I'm sorry. What?
What happened? Why oh
my god
You have what what is happening
The fuck is that
What is it what is happening I
Have no idea. Oh that leaks down to the exit hallway. I need to I
Need to go out that and make a left or something fucking soap. What are you doing? Oh,
Oh, I know what's happening he's walking by this hallway that I'm a Jason is gonna happen again I bet
No, which means he might have gone the other way I guess it's every time he comes by this hallway
He gets close enough to trigger that effect
Fucking terrifying breath, so I don't know which way he went then I'm gonna move
Left down here in here
Okay, good. I don't know if this is good or bad
Doesn't feel good
But I gotta explore these last few plays. Okay? Why Oh,
God stop that (Scared Mark)
Stop it
Stop it you
Consternated bitch. Okay. I haven't seen a body or anything like that. So I don't know what
They mean by Oh
Saw that you have you have to stop that
You have to it's the law. Oh, where am I? Oh god, where am I? Where am I? Oh god. Oh, no, wait, wait. Oh
Boy, okay
That was a mistake. Okay. Oh, it's a big empty room. Okay. Was there something in there?
There might have actually been something in there Oh
Fine okay, you're fine. You're fine. You're fine. He's going that way so would unless he comes in there
Where am I going? I don't know. Oh
Okay. All right. Um, where am I I've kind of lost my position here. I don't know where I am
God dammit. Okay. Um, I don't think that was okay. This is the hallway that means
My god whoo nice pants nice pants nice pants. Um, I don't know where I am. Um, what room is that? I don't know
Oh boy, he's mad
He's grumpy. He wants me
Can't get me though
stupid oh
God no, that's not good. Okay. That's okay. Is he just on me now forever? Can we go? I'm a girl. I'ma go
Go
I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm going you can't get me cuz I'm going I don't know where I'm going
I've lost myself again. No boy. I've lost I'm lost. I'm lost. I don't know where I am. Okay
Ah, this is that hallway, okay
So if this is that there's only a few other places that I need to go to check. Can I get down here?
I'm gonna take a left ducking here. Okay. Ah, this is where he was chasing me, right? Okay
No, no, no, no no no no, no, no. No, we're
Nothing nothing nothing a lot of nothing just nothing whole lot of nothing okay a lot of nothing I think I've checked everywhere
I can't think of any other place that I haven't checked
Says the key to this chest is in his chest your fur into the killer with the knife cuz I don't know how I'm gonna
Get into that just to be perfectly honest. I don't know how that's gonna happen
But uh if that's what you want, I suppose I can tango if I just keep wandering around eventually
I'm both gonna run into him and then maybe running to something else. I don't know nothing nothing
and
nothing
Fucking god
Dammit stop that shit cure over there, which is good cause that gives me time to look over here. Oh
My god, you gotta stop doing that man. You gotta stop doing that. There's not cool. There's a million times not cool
Man you gotta stop. So uncool. So very uncool. Oh
Fuck
Okay, I'm just going for it I don't know how okay did I get away am I faster than you
Is that what I'm understanding about this equation is that I'm faster than you
Come on Oh
God okay. I don't know where that was. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. He may he boy. He he he's my head. He's mad
He's mad
Okay
All right. I don't know where I am
But okay, but now that I know I can kind of run away from him that makes it a little bit better now
I don't need to be so skittish ceci anticipation that kills you. It's just like it's the reluctance. It's the
Apprehension. That's what I said. That's a big word. I used. It's the apprehension that really gets to you. It's not like that
There's a monster that makes it scary. It's that there's a monster that you don't know what it can do. That's scary. That's
What really scares people?
Oh, hi. Okay. Goodbye. I've looked through these before. I've looked through all this before
I've looked through all of this
Every nook every cranny. I've looked through these
Yeah, the key is in H is chest. What does does that have any significant H is chest?
Is that like significant in a way?
Where okay, I'm just gonna turn this on because I haven't used it at all TomSka
Okay, that's not good man, they really want to do that, okay
Cool good good to know
Just a use this cuz I haven't and I'm just gonna yeah
I see nothing. I see so much nothing. Just a whole lot of nothing a whopping
Heaping helping of nothing. Oh, hey bud. Just a big ol
Butt donk a donk of nothing is the graffiti any hint a helpful hint into who?
Can I get out?
The hell the door won't up. What the hell? Oh
Man you had a lot more of this than I thought you did. I hope I'm not just wasting it all here
I definitely might be wasting this cuz if there's more game after this then oh there. Oh hi, um,
Find and find a knife find a knot. How did I miss that? Oh, god. How did I miss that? Okay
Find a knife. Oh, where am I gonna what the hell? Wait what the body's gone? Wait. What? Oh, it didn't spawn it. Oh
That's dumb
That's dumb. Okay, so find a knife. We're am I gonna find a knife? Okay
All right, I guess more running then. I can't believe that that was right
I've walked by that so many times and I haven't seen a knife anywhere. Where's a knife?
Whoa, hey, buddy, sorry, you caught me with my pants down
Whoa, whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa, whoa, whoa. Hey, whoa, whoa. Whoa, stop that stop it
How do I get out of here? Oh geez? Okay. Well I was gonna go that way but I guess not anymore cool great
Thank you. Thank you for that. I don't know where I am
I don't know where I'm going knife knife knife knife knife knife knife. Anybody got a knife knife anybody knife knife knife
Somebody knife me. I'm gonna throw me a knife
whoa
There's that snapping again. Hello. Hey, how are you?
Wow
Stop that
nonsense
What are you doing? No, no, no. No, what you doing? Where you going? And it disappeared? What what just happened?
Where'd you go? Do you like morph into a different part of it so we can randomly appear anywhere in the map?
I'm almost out of
Looking juice. I mean, he's got a knife. I don't know how to get a knife from him
I don't think he's willing to give me a knife
I mean he's willing to give me the knife but only temporarily and in not in my hand Oh
What really oh, you're gonna do it like that, okay found a knife that was not there before that was definitely not there
Okay, so if I remember where the body was?
Found the chest key. Okay high chest key get it. It's funny
Okay, I think I go back now would not be a good time to suddenly run into him like a asshole
Right here
Found orange door key? Okay good now I just have to make it out and down
I'm being cautious
Because I don't want to ruin it right at the end. I
Fuck he's near. Okay. Where are you?
There's a door right there that leads straight down to it
By fucking god damn it. Is he gonna go by that door?
Where is he goddammit? Okay, you didn't go by that door which leads me to believe that he's not coming down that way
So I should be good going down here straight down
Good. Yep, I'm good. I got this game easy. Oh
You know, you've got to be kidding me. There's more really there's more. Oh my god. Okay, well
Great. Okay. Good. Great. Oh my god. That's huge. That's so big big and beefy
Alright, well, it's gonna take a lot more running I guess. Um
Huh, I don't even know where I came in is there even a way out of here. Oh, I see it, okay
I am not on a percent sure where I came in. I really don't know I
I
Got a green or but that's good I guess Wow I got a green orb. What does that mean? I
Wasted all of my seeing juice and I I've got no more. I've got no way to replenish it. Okay. Oh
Boy, oh boy
Containers
Dead ends great good great. Oh boy
So now I can't hide in those nooks or the crannies. Oh
Okay, can't through this lock doesn't use keys. Okay, so there's got to be like a switch or something something that needs an orb
I need to look at my map for just a second. I need to find a place to rest my eyes my weary
Oh, wait, did I already make a circle?
No, there's no um, I have no idea where I am. I think those containers were on the top, right?
Cuz I would make sense if the door was over there and then I came in over there. Okay? Oh
Oh God. Stop that stop it stop. Are you the only thing in here?
I think both of them are in here for some reason. Oh
I should have known that it was just easy mode before I should have known I have no idea what I'm I have no idea
Why or how I'm gonna get whatever I need to get I have no idea. It's just so labyrinthian
These are the same containers. I think or these are the different containers
There's two container sections judging by what's on the map here. This is the more regular one with an outside route
So it must be the other container. So there anything in here that I need?
Anything useful not by the looks of it
I don't know why but I'm alive and I don't know how and I don't know why but I'm alive. Oh
Boy, oh boy. Ooh big bongos. Oh
great, big bazongas great big bangle ooga lose Oh
Huge honkin bazongas. Okay. I think I know where I am
Surprisingly, yeah
Okay, there's no reason to go back. I think there might be a reason
Why why why why oh you must have been closer than I would have liked
I think that thing just goes right through walls, which is fine because hey, I like to do that, too
I just happen to go under him
Pause real quick. I need to look I have no idea where I am
Okay, that look was useless because I have no idea where I am. Oh
But oh hi, bud. Okay. That's weird. Okay. Oh
Hi, bud. Okay, that's weird. Don't come back
Maybe gosh, oh my
Could we not do that? Could we not do that? That is something that we could not do? Oh my goodness
I have seen nothing. It's a big maze
Just a big freakin maze and it's just gonna be pure happenstance
if I find something combing this thing for hours and be lucky to find even one thing that I need a little own - I
Mean I came across a green orb, which is actually pretty impressive. I think by pure happenstance
I found a green orb, which probably is very useful, but I have no idea where a green orb would go is the thing
Trying to loop back a few times
I'm trying to loop back a few times so that I make sure I don't miss anything
Trying to make big sweeping paths across this shit
was that
About I haven't there's a special. Oh, I did it. Oh god. There's three orbs
Okay, so this is by alright, so I need to find more orbs now judging by how the last thing went
I think the orbs must spawn in when you find one and then another right that's got to be it
But now I know where to deliver them. So I need to find two more orbs
Oh god, you got to stop that man. You got to stop it. You've got to stop that that is
No bueno, right? Why where where where what? Oh god, I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead
I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm I'm dead. I'm so bad. I'm so good
I'm dead. I'm not dead. Oh
I think I saw it popping out of the wall there that was good. I was comforting. Oh
Hi Wow, you are awful. I hate you know, what?
Oh
It just sends me back to the beginning what with no progress or what
Why what happened? Where are you? Oh
Okay. Yeah, that's it. You just cuz you send me back. That's it sock came over
I miss kind of game over right? Maybe it resets my progress. I don't know weird my
Night vision is still gone though. So it's like a soft reset I guess. Oh
No, it resets my progress. Oh god. Damn it. Okay. Well shit god damn
That's intense, you know
I've uh
Man I've been doing this for like an hour now
I've no like I have no idea how long it would take me to get through this but I'm gonna end this for now and
Just say holy shit. That was really scary. It's lost some of its care now
Then I know it's not too much of a threat, but that was still very very terrifying at first
I may revisit this at some point since I ran out of time for this episode
But thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below if you want to play this for yourself and have your what took is
Scared off. I'll put a link in the description really good stuff, though
So thank you everybody so much for watching if you want to see consternation one
I'll link it in the description whose many years ago, but still very good. So thanks again now as always I'll see you
Bye-bye